[Music]
as a huge fan of superheroes obviously
if you've read my stuff you might have
worked out that i actually enjoy what i
do um i am
equally a fan of fantasy books this is
what i read growing up and so
having the opportunity to mash two
things that i love so much
and create an only universe
with that mashing
is just ridiculous it makes me
incredibly happy
so this is how this book starts it
starts with a whole lot of ominous it
starts with a whole lot of threat and
for people like
black lightning jefferson pierce what it
means for him as the king of a kingdom
what it means for his subjects what it
means for his people what it means for
his two daughters and his son is a
threat
[Music]
so yeah turning batman into an actual
night was pretty easy really i mean it's
right there in the name we've got the
dark knight we just
made it armor he already covers himself
in body armor we just yasmin putri just
went and made that amazing
um it makes a lot of sense once you get
into the book once you understand his
role and he is essentially a witcher he
is finding
magic in the world and
stopping it he sees magic as kind of
crime in a way so that is his quest
i will say harley quinn isn't just the
court jester she's also the court
advised you know there's a point where
batman says you know you're paid to
juggle and she's like well no i paid to
do both i can i can advise and i can
juggle so i can tell you that you should
get rid of the cows because they don't
make you look scary they just make me
want to pet you and give you treats
then we have things like yes they go off
to search for a banshee and that turns
out to be
black canary um and i have to give props
to my son for that because he literally
one day said dad you should make black
canary banshee i'm like that's really
clever okay i'm using that
[Music]
but we talked a lot about
what places would look like what what
the l kingdom looked like what black
lightning's kingdom looked like where
john constantine came from but largely
when you're working with someone like
you guys from tree who is so
so good at this and so detailed um she
she has a million ideas and she was
sending us
pages of ideas of concepts not just art
but where she was taking this from
history what culture she was taking it
from
through history um i it makes my job
very very easy i don't need to describe
much i just know that if i say
it's kind of this jasmine will say it's
this
[Music]
on page four
we do something that's never been done
uh in a dc book before something that
turns everything on its head um and by
page seven we sort of
twist that even further and by page 26
which is the last page of issue one i
pretty much guarantee that we'll have
every dc found on board to desperately
see what happens next but this dark
knights of steel this is
tom taylor as a child everything i love
being mashed together as i said
and just going for it and going full
pills like just yeah you wait
[Music]
[Music]
you